just want to start with your question at
pmqs saying that David Cameron Commons
Nick Clegg to drop his Pledge on
University tuition fees does the PM
intend to take the credit for convincing
the leader at the labor party to do
likewise I mean it sounds a bit like one
of those planted questions you get from
the government benches I've very much uh
not the case um what I was I was seeking
to do there was just to highlight the
absurdity of Libra's position you know
kirst armor when he became labor leader
came in with a number of pledges that
you made to the the Libra membership and
ultimately pledges to the public as well
and he's driving again on many of them
not least the one Innovation to free
tuition and that's really helpful for
the conservative point when just look at
the response from Rishi sunak I Thank
The Honorable gentleman for the question
it is hard to keep up with the list of
broken promises well I I think in
relation to this particular issue
there's a clear divide in line between
the Scottish national party and the
labor party of course in Scotland under
the the Scottish government led by by
humza Yusuf we have free tuition it's
why I'm sat here today because I was one
of the very many beneficiaries uh of
that as so many other people have been
and now we have a labor leader who's
seeking to elicit change who wants to
get young people to Aspire for a better
future who's saying that his pledge
which he made to them a very important
pledge now no longer matters he doesn't
want to abolish tuition fees and match
the match the priorities of the SNP but
you can see why you're really going for
kissed armor here right and Richard may
think it's actually quite helpful I mean
are you a little bit worried that you
know SMP supporters looking at the state
of your party right now might switch to
the labor party I'm old enough to
remember when they were the largest part
in Scotland well well I think there's
been a lot of speculation in relation to
that but the point of my question today
was to highlight that it's the SNP who
are looking to protect young people's
futures and as the SNP Who deliver free
tuition for for people in Scotland and
that's not just that's not just a slight
the concern the liberal practice it's
like the conservatives as well and
indeed the lab dams and the whole point
of that was was to structure the fact
that you know Westminster is the one
that's taken us out of the European
Union you have the three big political
parties uh in Westminster three
established Westminster parties want to
go back in who want to limit the
opportunities for young people and here
we have it again when it comes to to
education and you have the Tories the
labor party in the lab dams if you don't
want to give young people that
opportunity that the SNP have given
young people and I think that's a clear
dividing line between the the Scottish
national party and all those parties not
just a labor party not just a tourists
not just love dance but all of them I
guess you know if you were a voter or
Swing Vote in particular looking at s p
right now though you might think look
are these guys really competent enough
to manage
other people's money when they can't
manage their own I mean you have been
scrambling to meet a deadline right and
to get the Auditors in to access this
money yeah it's not a great look at it
so so it's I don't think anyone can or
will shy away from the challenges that
we've faced internally uh or obviously
the parties had its issues
um north of the border and down here
we've had challenges in relation to
meeting me in the audit that like I'm
actually delighted that we can now uh
confirm that we have an auditor in place
and where we're looking forward to to
getting that deadline which is the end
of May uh hit because it's important
that we have access to that to that
resource in order to pay our staff in
the open at the the Forefront of this
discussion and I think some of the
politics around it has been a bit
uncomfortable in that regard because it
was their jobs their livelihoods and the
support that they provide us that we
were seeking to protect I mean what is
going on like you say it's we're talking
about missing out on 1.2 million having
to let people go well well of course
we're not going to be letting anyone
going we're going to hit them we're
going to hit the table it was very it
was very challenging and you know I I
found out in February um about the
situation the fact that we didn't have
an order since then we've been trying to
a secure one we've done that now and but
there's been challenges
how did you react when you first find
that out well I I think when I first
found out I didn't actually think it was
a huge deal because I thought it would
be quite straightforward to go and
secure a new order or that obviously
didn't prove to be the case but now
we've got one I'm I'm just delighted to
go over that and we can get back to
talking about politics I guess the issue
is does it feed into wider concerns
about the s p and management of money
your party is subject to a fraud
investigation north of Border we've seen
people being arrested you know forensic
tents outside houses
motorhomes being seized I mean a lot of
people will be looking at this it sounds
like something out of a TV drama after
they trust the s p I think those those
individuals that have obviously been
um they've been contacted by the police
now would be a mess of me to delve to
delve into that but look we need to get
a house in order how hamza's done a lot
up till now in relation to that we've
got a governance review in place and I'm
looking forward to the outcome without
coming forward because we need to be in
a better place internally as a party as
a member it's frustrating for me to know
and to learn some of these things in the
media and to obviously learn about
things uh after the fact I don't think
that's that's helpful and I think across
our membership that's how we feel but
look we've been in government uh for a
long time and the reason we've been in
government for a long time is people of
Scotland trust us to deliver them for
them and situation fees as a clear
example of where we have done things
different we've done things better and
we'll continue to do that it's
interesting you're saying that how you
felt frustrated as a member to be I
guess kept out the loop of things do you
think there's been like a culture of
secrecy uh I think what we've seen since
hamza's came in is certainly more
openness more transparency and I think
that's a good thing I've tried to be as
upfront as I possibly can on all of
these things as well so was it open and
transparent before then I think people
can read between the lines and assess
the fact that if members of the party I
don't even think the deputy leader of
the party uh was aware of certain
aspects of of things that had happened I
don't think that's that's helpful
um but we have a new leadership team in
place homes has really focused on making
sure that we resolve these problems
we've got the governance review in place
he's been very open very forthright with
the with the media on on all of the
queries in relation to these things and
we need to keep that going because what
matters most of them politics is trust
and the public need to trust us they've
they've placed our trust in us for a
long long time and we need to make sure
that they continue to do so into the
future we wrong to place your trust in
the Clusters now
and she let you down uh no I mean I
I know what you have kind of trying to
allude to here and in relation to some
of the challenges within the party but
you know Nicholas dungeon led us to
election Victory after election Victory
she was she was supremely talented and
supremely successful could things have
been done differently in terms of the
way the property operates in that
respect I think everyone would probably
nod their head and say yeah it probably
should have been done differently and
bahams is doing things differently
that's a good thing I've been really
impressed by him up till now I think
he's certainly uh gone down well with
the public back home as well and
hopefully we can go on to positive new
days because you know what a lot of
people are were projecting the demise of
the Scottish national party that that
ain't happening we're just getting
started you speak very highly obviously
of your new leader Hamza Yusuf he has
said it's been in his words I think I
can say this on TV uh bloody frustrating
it hasn't been the ideal honeymoon for
him no it's not
um but but look at what he's managed to
achieve in those six weeks he's managed
to put forward his own prospectus uh for
government and around the quality and
opportunities we reset our relationship
with business which was badly needed
he's reset his relation ship with
businesses in northeast of Scotland
energy and businesses which is very
important from my perspective he's put
cost of living at the very Forefront of
everything that he's doing he's had a
number of policy pledges up until now in
relation to providing support for those
who are in dire circumstances
circumstances created by people down
here in Westminster who've cashed the
entire UK economy and the Scottish
government's having the time pick up the
pieces where where it can he had an
anti-poverty Summit today which shows
that his he's focused on meeting the
challenges that that are there for the
people of Scotland and whilst he's been
doing all that he's also been sorting
out things within the party you know it
took us six months to to get an auditor
of to look for an order in six weeks how
many use of delivered one uh you know
that's that's the manner of what he's
achieved now I'm really excited about
what's coming in the future I was quite
interested to see his comments on free
School meals in Scotland he was saying
look he's got a child uh who is I can't
remember the exact age but in school
there you go is it right for other
people to be paying for meals for his
children well what's your take on that
so what he was referring to there was
the the free skill meals that exist in
Scotland so at this moment in time most
of the Year groups in Primary School are
covered and we're looking to expand that
to primary six and primary seven which
is a really good thing and as I
understand it I think there's many pilot
schemes in relation to secondary schools
as well but we then need to have that
discussion about what does that look
like in secondary schools and just part
of that I mean we don't just need to
reflect upon how much money families
have in their pocket but also what the
habits are of people in secondary school
because I'm sure you like me uh your
habits change somewhere the older you
got but at the heart of this is the fact
that the SNP in Scotland whether it's
free tuition whether it's uh free School
meals whether it's free prescriptions
whether it's lower council tax so on and
so forth we've been at the Forefront of
providing Progressive policies and we'll
continue to do that
coronation this weekend are you going to
be pledging allegiance to the king I
believe I already have
and how are you going to be celebrating
uh I'll be there I'll be there on
Saturday
um look I'm I'm not a monarchist I've
been quite open about that in the past
um but I represent everyone uh and all
communities in Scotland so I'll be there
on their behalf to to make sure that
they're represented because that's the
that's the right thing to do it's it's
the grown-ups thing to do and I'll
obviously be there with the first
minister of Scotland as well it is an
independent Scotland do you think King
Charles should be the Monarch I think
it's important that the people of
Scotland if they want to change have the
opportunity to change that applies to
everything and not just the monarchy not
just the Constitution but all aspects of
things nothing nothing should be out of
the reach of the Scottish people when it
comes to deciding what their
constitutional future so a potential
referendum then on the monarchy of the
people of Scotland so so wanted that to
be the case and but you know what I
think is important is to recognize the
fact that we do have a head of state and
whilst we've got a head of state they'll
have my respect okay thank you very much
good to talk